[Musique]
embarquement immédiat pour rio de
janeiro là où le brésil s'invente un
nouvel avenir à la veille de plusieurs
événements planétaires
le thermomètre du pays continent est en
surchauffe
pour découvrir ce qui fait vibrer les
cariocas les habitants de rio qu'il soit
artiste expatriés figurent des favelas
où amoureux de la mer il faut plonger en
profondeur dans cette capitale du
métissage en pleine renaissance
les minimes ailleurs la reine des
bikinis invente des modèles haute
couture qui font fureur sur les plages
une nature envoûtante un décor de rêve
il faut prendre de la hauteur pour
explorer l'envers de la carte postale
entre mer et montagne les favelas des
quartiers qui ont longtemps fait peur
depuis peu des gringos les investisse
axel un jeune français a décidé de
devenir favelas dos pour y construire sa
pousada une maison d'hôtes à la
brésilienne dans les quartiers nord de
rio un immense lagon artificiel bien
loin de la jet set d'ipanema
celui que l'on surnomme fait jean le
patron de la piscine des favelas est une
figure locale qui veut transformer
l'image de ces quartiers déshérités au
sud de rio un chapelet d'îles sauvage
katia une jeune plongeuse a décidé de
tout faire pour préserver la vie des
dauphins les sentinelles de ce petit
paradis
aujourd'hui menacée par la folle
ascension du brésil
[Musique]
d'un extrême à l'autre voyage au brésil
à rio de janeiro dans l'une des villes
les plus extravagantes du moment
ipanema 9 heures du matin
sur son vélo électrique l'énigme
ailleurs vient chaque matin chercher
l'inspiration
tout a commencé pour elle sur cette
plage tout droit venu de sao paulo et
elle a débarqué ici pour la première
fois dans les années 70 comment tu vas
je veux bien et toi à quel délice
la première fois que je suis arrivé ici
j'ai eu le souffle coupé
à rio de janeiro à l'époque le bikini
était tout petit et on les met pour cela
mais on voulait être un peu plus
couverts pour être plus confortable mais
ça n'existait pas
mes copines à sao paulo me demandait de
ramener des maillots plus large et du
coup je me suis dit que j'allais en
créer un
j'ai pris un ancien paréo à moi je les
coupe et c'est une chose très artisanal
la chance c'est que je savais coudre ça
a été un succès et tout le monde a
commencé à passer des commandes
j'étais moi-même le mannequin je les
ramener à la plage pour en offrir à des
copines et c'est ainsi moment que tout a
commencé
toulouse nous remet rouler en acheter et
porté les bikinis de l'aîné lors j'ai
alors créé une petite fabrique au
fondement garage dans le quartier de la
gloire
c'était une autre époque
du simple de pièces à la version string
le plus grand défilé au monde de bikini
a lieu sur les plages de rio de janeiro
c'est le costume de la girl from ipanema
des filles qui défilent toute la journée
sur la plage un cocktail détonant
mélange de soleil d'eau et de culte du
corps métissé qui a révolutionné l'image
du brésil
le bikini un petit bout de tissu qui
n'est pourtant pas né au brésil
tout a commencé à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale le 1er juillet 46 a eu
lieu sur l'atoll de bikini dans l'océan
pacifique une explosion atomique
le but de l'opération validée la
puissance destructrice de la bombe à
attention mais une des explosions les
plus impressionnantes de l'histoire
provoquant des tsunamis de plus de 30
mètres de haut
cinq jours plus tard louis réard un
ingénieur mécanicien français invs en
khl deux pièces qu'il surnomme bikini en
référence à l'explosion atomique qui
vient d'avoir lieu
du jamais vu le sulfureux maillot de
bain fut interdite sur de nombreuses
plages on le déclare dangereux pour la
santé
c'est à partir des années 60 qu'il se
démocratise brigitte bardot s'affiche
légèrement vêtues et hollywood
l'adoptent dans la foulée
louis réard a réussi son coup le bikini
est devenue culte
il a conquis les femmes du monde entier
retour à rio dans la capitale du bikini
pour rencontrer la reine des maillots de
bain il faut se rendre dans le quartier
très chic de lagor un lac au milieu de
la ville et en face des hôtels
particuliers
c'est ici que vit les minimes ailleurs
ça c'est le roi de la maison
tiens ça c'est pour toi mon petit chien
c'est bon le brésil est de loin le
numéro un mondial sur le marché du
bikini 300 millions de pièces vendues
chaque année un enjeu national est une
formidable opportunité pour les nids
elle a fait fortune en créant des
collections de luxe bien plus qu'un
simple maillot de bain il est ici à rio
une seconde peau
l'esprit carioca c'est la plage peu
importe que tu es de l'argent ou pas
tout le monde est content de se mélanger
on dit toujours que la plage est très
démocratique ici mais en fait il y à des
tribus d'un coup d'oeil on va savoir
d'où tu viens
cela dépend de la manière dont tu portes
le bikini en fonction de la taille la
couleur les chapeaux les accessoires que
tu utilises cela permet d'identifier les
femmes plus que n'importe quel homme et
cela est très amusant si les gens me
disaient vous n'êtes pas d'ici quelle
blague
nous arrivons maintenant dans mon
entreprise dans le quartier de botafogo
tout à l'heure en femme d'affaires
avisée
lenny a rendez vous avec ses
fournisseurs pour choisir les tissus de
la prochaine saison
bonjour bonjour je les jours salut les
nids pas mal pas mal fort collège vous
voyez un petit café non je vous remercie
regarde les nids j'ai trouvé ce tissu
avec des petits trous plus petits
regarde il est pas mal si j'adore
soumaïla je le trouve gracieux j'aime la
base c'est quoi la baisse du prix de
celui-ci au noir je vois ça tout de
suite les mais tu me fais un super prix
pour moi il était il y à aussi en faux
cuir matière prix photo line y supervise
le moindre détail
maintenant je suis en train de finir
d'éditer un catalogue avec des photos de
michael roberts
mais je suis à la fin de ma collection
d'hiver et je suis en train de préparer
ma collection pour l'été prochain
son défi être à l'avant-garde pour
surprendre chaque été avec de nouvelles
créations à l'étagé du dessous les
petites mains du bikini donne vie aux
croquis de l'aîné
il y à plus d'une centaine de fabricants
à rio pour un marché qui dépasse le
milliard d'euros comme dans une maison
de haute couture l'ennemi gère tout à
domicile
voici
[Musique]
ici travaillent 150 personnes dans la
production et
et c'est très important de travailler
dans le même endroit car comme ça je
peux accompagner de près toutes les
étapes de la fabrication ont fait
environ 1000 bikini par jour en temps
normal
et d'ici les bikinis partent en voyage
aux prêts pour habiller les brésiliennes
les française les américaines les
anglaises et cetera c'est dieu le veut
il y a les bikinis pour le marché
mondial est dans une petite salle à part
un laboratoire dans lequel s'invente le
bikini du futur bien par ici ici c'est
la salle d'assemblage c'est là que tout
n'est aussi à travaillent avec moi
depuis 15 ans j'ai un modèle de chaque
bikini qu'on a créé il y en ad foot ça
c'est le bikini qui est totalement tissé
à la main par exemple ce maillot a été
créé pour le défilé de la collection
d'été de l'année dernière et fait avec
de la peau d'un vrai qu'au bras
évidemment on fait l'édition exclusive
et limitée mais la complexité pour le
fabriquer c'est de réussir à utiliser de
la peau de serpent sur un maillot ça a
été un vrai succès car c'est très
original
on a déjà vu l'utilisation du serpent
pour fabriquer des chaussures des sacs à
main mais faire un maillot de bain en
peau de serpent
c'était la première fois l'ont fait
c'était une vraie réussite dans les
défilés de mode
un autre modèle qui a été un défi pour
nous c'est un bandage unique une seule
pièce dans le genre gladiateurs
en pot de cobra aux façons de la diète
heures rien de tel pour prendre un
dernier bain de soleil sur la plage
d'ipanema
18 heures le rendez vous des vrais
carioca
après le boulot ils prennent le temps de
vivre en famille ou profitent d'une
dernière vague
[Musique]
au petit matin axel un jeune français
conquis par riot guide les touristes
loin des sentiers battus
la plage d'ipanema tu la vois
correctement que d'ici tout en suivant
la paix ghana par 1 cellier fait des
merveilles du monde naturel à leurs
pieds les joyaux de rio mais aussi ses
immenses bidonvilles à flanc de colline
c'est la favela de roffignac c'est la
plus grande panne grave si voix basse et
le début de rossi n'a accroché à la
montagne des deux frères la favela de
vie djigueul un dédale de constructions
anarchiques qui surplombe l'océan
axel s'est spécialisé dans ce tourisme
d'un nouveau genre et donc voilà pavel
haas est tout le temps en en
construction s'est jamais figé les mains
qui ne s'arrête jamais
la visite de ces quartiers défavorisés
il doit prendre des photos n'hésite pas
il y a deux ans axel était étudiant en
école de commerce et il a tout plaqué
pour riom depuis il voit ses quartiers
d'un autre oeil
plus simplement un point où la vie est
misérable mais aussi une opportunité
pour se faire une place au soleil des
prix accessibles et des points de vue
spectaculaires
il a investi toutes ses économies dans
cette maison avec vue sur le pain de
sucre
il a ouvert ici une maison d'hôtes dans
la favela et les clients viennent du
monde entier
aujourd'hui ce sont des colombiens une
grille d alvaro qui sont intéressés par
ce nouveau concept
salut ingrid va bien ici c'est le
premier étage et les chambres sont en
bas je vais vous montrer
il y en a plusieurs et on discutera de
celles que vous souhaitez louer
bon allez on y va lance là
moi je comptabilise centre avenia moi je
vais le cacher c'est vraiment trop de
bazas bien sûr on doit encore faire des
améliorations
[Musique]
voilà il ya un autre salon bas toutes
les chambres sont occupées mais celle là
ne se libèrent normalement fin juillet
il faut que vérifier avec le locataire
nous on viendrait à partir du mois
d'août
si c'est possible à qui elle au magazine
ici en vérité c'était une cuisine et
regardez il ya toujours les vielles on a
caché en dessous paquet à pire
le lavabo ici avant c'était une cuisine
et on a peint on a fait ça est heureux
commission a réussi donc
ingrid 1 parce que alvaro il travaille
dans un bar à santa teresa et puis il a
discuté avec un de mes amis comme quoi
il cherchait une chambrée cet ami en
question m'a mis en relation avec eux
voilà ce qu'ils sont de colombie et il
voyage pendant 11 ème édition un an et
donc il voulait poser leurs bagages un
petit peu à rio pour profiter et
découvrir la ville en plus plus en
profondeur
cette vue est unique accor si vous
travaillez dans le coin le quartier
tranquille
le visuel de santa teresa normalement
c'est plus vers la zone nord là ici
c'est superbe
il ya des personnes qui louent des
chambres improvisé dans la favela
il ya de plus en plus de touristes qui
choisissent cette formule 'taux liste
ici c'est bien
il a fait des travaux d amélioration
l'espace est agréable
dans les autres maisons que l'on a
visité il y a des murs improvisé parfois
avec une planche en bois
c'est très mal fait et en plus c'est
cher cette chambre ici elle coûte 250
euros tout compris avec 250 euros par
mois donc avec avec tout cas internet et
si tu mènes gens comme ça dans un hôtel
combien tu peux encore améliorer pas
dans un automne mais ne serait-ce que en
bas dans un une colocation lambda dans
un immeuble normale à rio aujourd'hui ça
montre tout de suite à 400 euros tout de
suite est une papa bien sûr cette vue
avec ce que moi je considère cette
qualité de vie si on veut très
tranquille c'est vraiment très posé non
il sera en bas d'un immeuble n'aura pas
de juge au fer chaud 3 pas d'air
sept chambres pour accueillir des
voyageurs latinos ou des saxophonistes
irlandais salue l'état ça vas y toi car
tu vas jouer aujourd'hui
ouais j'ai un concert tu joues au club
du maze a la garde
une auberge espagnole emilio un
brésilien de la classe moyenne vient de
s'installer dans la favela un choix
inimaginable il ya encore quelques
années
c'est curieux parce que si je suis
pareil a même eu deux trois ans - vas-y
que d'aller habiter dans une favela avec
des étrangers et ça se passerait trop
bien il n'y a pas de souci mais voilà je
suis là mais tout se passe bien
c'est une situation improbable ouais
même encore pour mes pattes brésilien tu
vas et sont ils viennent ici j'adore et
trouve saint prime s'est aussi déjà une
surprise de trouver un endroit comme ça
ça fait ça fait pas partie de nos vies
tu as finalement avant de venir vivre et
si je n'avais pas l'habitude d'aller
dans les favelas où dans des endroits
pareils et c'est encore étonnant ma
famille qui vient mais pat qui viennent
c'est trop bien ça se passe bien mais
c'est quand même un petit choc pendant
longtemps les favelas de rio étaient des
quartiers hors-la-loi trafiquants de
drogue et police ce livre est ici une
guerre sans merci
jusqu'au jour où le gouvernement décide
d'employer les grands moyens
plus de 3000 militaires investissent les
quartiers les plus chauds de la ville
lors d'opérations dit de pacification
oui
l'état reprend la main les favelas
redevient fréquentable
[Musique]
une révolution pour ces quartiers qui
vivaient sous l'emprise des gangs les
habitants respirent
axel et ses locataires peuvent
aujourd'hui vivre en paix
remonter au clan va chercher des lits
donc c'est vicente qui m'a préparé des
lits en une structure métallique voir ça
c'est sympa il a fait tout un système je
trouve à pouvoir la chante quoi dans la
chambre la chambre accordions ou
temporaires que j'appelle et on va
pouvoir les rabattre complètement contre
un mur et heureusement que tu es là
parce que c'est un petit peu lourd quand
c'est du beau faire un personnage il a
il a une maison assez particulière il
habite en bas par contre dans la favela
donc on va devoir tout monté tout en bas
de la favela ils vont voir le champion
local du système d le dénommé vicens
spécialiste en soudure et ferronnerie il
fini de transformer des portes
grillagées en lits 17
tu vas bien non ça me prendra encore un
peu de temps combien de temps en une
quinzaine de minutes
c'est bientôt fini quinze minutes on
peut pas le finir là au cic bon élève
présente à qui on va là je te présente
valentin il va nous aider pour monter le
matériel car à deux ça va être trop dur
il prendra les pièces les moins lourds
mais n'en resta moi j'ai plutôt sur le
côté bas de la favela
il vit ici depuis comme quoi tout 32 ans
ça fait 32 ans que je vis ici il est ici
il a connu les favelas comment tout
était fort et juste la forest tous les
petits travaux à faire dans la favela
sidiki les faits les porte en fer les
fenêtres les barbecues du budget l'écart
de samia fils kadhafi
on va dès que quelqu'un a besoin de
quelque chose en fer ces visages qui est
qui le prépare ici dans son atelier ici
c'est une petite faveur
tout le monde fait rend des services
financiers opaques
[Applaudissements]
présent dans le jeu
[Musique]
alors ça
et
l'avis du favelas dos est une vie de
montagnards il faut sans cesse escalader
des milliers de marche pas simple
bon
les visages la peinture n'est pas sèche
ça ne tachent les vêtements combien ça
pèse cela doit peser 20 kg beach qui est
assez léger mon gars on dirait que ça
pèse 40 kg tu es un gringalet
trente minutes d'ascension sont
nécessaires pour arriver chez axel
[Musique]
m
profitez de la vue incroyable et plus
haut de la favela cela se mérite
ça commence à être un peu dur là on
n'est qu'à la moitié mais bon tous les
jours mais sans ce poids quoi raphaël
arrive dans pas longtemps la paléo le
téléphone plus le lie au choix 10 ans et
raphaël qui arrivait sur sa pas se
presser un petit peu donc rafael c'est
mon grand ami et et grands un partenaire
de mon aventure avec la maison avec qui
donc j'ai acheté la maison il ya un an
et demi et l'a donc rafa lui devait
finir ses études d'architecturé en
france nous fier et très content de
revenir et moi aussi quoi de le recevoir
sur tout ça tu es fatigué mais ça va un
moment qu'on arrive dans cinq minutes
singh comme une autre
alors
la favela c'est comme un petit village
ça lui fait une fête à la maison
ok sympa je vais venir avec ma femme on
pouvait venir percuter
allez on se doit ce soir super voilà
c'est mes voisins proches et donc ce
parent on a organisé une petite une
petite fête pour l'arrivée de raphaël
justement et j'en profite pour inviter
un de tous les voisins ça c'est beaucoup
comme ça ici à savoir s'invite au
dernier moment les gens que tu croises
quoi mais bon ça va vite à les enfants
donc ils le savent tous déjà à quelle
heure à partir de 7 heures j'ai aussi
invité ta mère ok très bien d'ailleurs
plein de monde ça va être super
brazil aragonite les brésiliennes sont
mignonnes ici dans la favela on n'a pas
à se plaindre
il ya pas mal de jolies filles ici mais
c'est un petit quartier quand mr ouai
mais dans tout rio voilà c'est autre
chose
il y en a pour tous les goûts chez accel
ambiance communautaire et il tord le
saxophoniste prépare le repas du soir
vincenz le roi de la débrouille installe
une chambre d'appoint sorti tout droit
de son imagination
si cassy voilà c'est ce que moi
j'appelle une heure une chambre
temporaire que je puisse déplier quand
j'ai besoin de deux lits pour recevoir
des amis des invités de manière
temporaire à quelques nuits et donc la
vie saine si on a travaillé avec visage
sur un système de grands panneaux en
bois qui se déplie vous allez voir ça
elle assure la porte
et voilà le travail une nouvelle chambre
à moindre frais
[Musique]
toute la petite maison s'affairent pour
fêter l'arrivée de l'associé d'axel
d'une cinquantaine de personnes sont
attendues
[Musique]
je m'appelle ramos et je viens déposer
raphaël tu connais avec les photos mais
pas tant que ça
[Musique]
cela fait plus d'un an qu'il n'est pas
venu raphaël découvre les changements en
france ça si tu veux te sentir vraiment
l'extérieur tu le sens extérieur quoi
pour toi pierre tout à fait
en face de la glace pour pouvoir avoir
de bière fraîche
[Musique]
ce soir des expatriés et des locaux sont
au rendez vous
et parmi eux l'ancien propriétaire des
lieux
sa voix on a fait 1 bat et là bas il ya
une baie vitrée
comment
je classe l'uci qui est l'ex
propriétaire de la maison et qui vient
avec sa petite fille à une amie ensuite
j'ai six jeunes rats mais un peu plus
tard dans la soirée
l or ricardo c'est le mari de marie
odette qui est la soeur de 10 si on y va
ou favelas au thon se connaissent et
petite famille et qu'est ce que vous
pensez d'accès lui demande un frère
c'est comme un frère un traitement
[Musique]
je suis contente de revoir mon ancienne
maison
il a bien profité de l'espace et vous
habitez ou maintenant j'habite le
quartier de baleines t c'est mieux là
bas c'est différent vous comprenez c'est
une maison mais je n'ai plus une aussi
belle je vais comme celle d'ici vous
avez quitté la favela
non là bas aussi c'est une favela
l'intérieur mais les plus près de la
route et que pensez-vous de la
transformation de votre ancienne maison
auras tu as c'est super beau je ne
m'attendais pas du tout à ça tu
comprends il a fait du bon boulot
j'espère que son affaire d'un marché des
favelas qui change de mains axel et son
camarade sont des pionniers peu de
gringos vivent encore dans ces quartiers
mais plus pour longtemps
[Musique]
des spots avec une vue incroyable une
idée qui commence à faire son chemin
vivre dans la favela n'est plus réservé
aux pauvres
face à l'explosion du prix de
l'immobilier à rio axel et raphaël ont
réussi un joli coup
ils vivent dans plus de 200 m² avec une
vue de millionnaire ils ont fait de gros
travaux de rénovation et c'est loin
d'être fini
le planning est chargé pas de plage au
programme mais maçonnerie et ravalement
bilan
ouais donc je disais je naquis près mon
p'tit déj enlèvement résumé raphaëlle
tout ce que tu veux faire de concret
quoi avant ton départ je veux qu'on peut
être qu'on aménage des espaces
extérieurs de la maison
ouais donc la terrasse assez cool on
prend le petit déj c'est mortel et ce
serait bien que des deux niveaux il a
accès à une sorte de terrasse comme ça
vu je sors plus propre et qu'on puisse
aussi à chacun d'accéder à son niveau
qui est plus vraiment enfin c'est un
mélange qui est cool mais les deux
niveaux soit plus d'indépendants en fait
ils sont plus indépendants et puis
qu'ils soient mieux c'est que ça
passerait par une terrasse qui n'existe
pas encore donc on va détruire l'escale
et voilà qui est là on va le déplacer un
peu à l'extérieur
du coup ça permettra aussi d'avoir un
accès privilégié à chaque chaque niveau
et puis ça permettra d'avoir une
terrasse prince soleil l'a donc diverses
coupes un ca de mettre une petite douche
extérieure en tout comme ça d'ailleurs
et c'est aujourd'hui rappelle avoir
parlé là favelas pacifiées
ce serait le nouvel eldorado pour les
bonnes affaires immobilières mais
attention acheter dans ces quartiers
n'est pas sans risque ici cette maison
là j'étais 50000 euros à partir de 55
ans
et ils me l'ont comme ça d'après taussat
le bund pourrait valoir 1 0 parce que
cette maison à l'apathie de propriété
puisqu'elle est pas reconnue parce que
du jour au lendemain on peut la détruire
et on peut partir et on a pris ce risque
avec raphaël on a fait ce pari ici quoi
on sait que
ça risque pas d'arriver quand même mais
comme il dit on n'a pas de titre de
propriété
comme tous les gens dans les favelas ça
viendra peut-être un jour mais bon on
est sous la pression de la culture aussi
des gens il ya quand même un cinquième
de la ville qui vit dans des favelas
il ya l'état quand même investi dans les
réseaux ici il s'est introduit quand
même il a il a fait des améliorations
donc tous les gens qui sont ici ont
construit leur maison foyer datant tous
plus ou moins un titre de propriété
après il ya une légende urbaine qui dit
que oui on aura forcément ça fait 34
ici aucune loi ne les protègent et de
nombreuses constructions sont insalubres
ou édifié sur des zones à risque mais
pour axel vivre ici ce n'est pas qu'une
question d'argent
moi j'aime pas parler de bonnes affaires
ou bon coup parce que vraiment avec
raphaël on n'a pas du tout acheté cette
maison en pensant qu'on allait devenir
millionnaire grâce à ça c'est beaucoup
plus lié à un coup de coeur avec cette
favela avec cette vue avec la ville de
rio et la culture carioca qui nous a
poussé à franchir le cap et d'investir
nos économies dans cette maison
construire des terrasses des escaliers
et des pièces supplémentaires
aucune autorisation à demander puisque
leurs maisons et illégale
l' aventure des gringos de la favela ne
fait que commencer
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là d'autres
favelas
celle des quartiers nord elles n'ont pas
la vue sur mer et une très mauvaise
réputation
pour s'y rendre il faut prendre
l'avenida brasil une artère de 58 km de
long autour de laquelle s'enchevêtrent
d' immenses bidonvilles au milieu la
piscine de ramos un des lieux les plus
insolites de la ville un immense lagon
artificiel
[Musique]
le rendez vous de tous les favelas dos
10h du matin la figure incontournable du
quartier fait jean leroy de la piscine
s'y rend en famille
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la passerelle numéro 13
qui nous emmène à la piscine géante de
ramos aujourd'hui ça va être la fête
avec un soleil merveilleux comme ça ça
va être remplie de famille
ces gens c'est un peu le grand frère et
à chaque fois c'est le même scénario
il vient tous les jours et il connaît
tout le monde ça c'est un copain
musicien tu fais un concert bientôt
ouais je joue le vendredi on se croise
là bas c'est l'un des hommes les plus
populaires des quartiers nord
tu vas bien on essaye de prendre un
petit verre ensemble ok bon sens alors
lui c'est un chef d'entreprise il fait
un boulot d'un gain
on se voit tout à l'heure cette piscine
a été créé il y a dix ans entre
l'autoroute et la baie de guanabara
une ancienne plage à succès devenu
aujourd'hui impropre à la baignade
le gouvernement ici a investi une
fortune pour tenter de dépolluer la baie
de guanabara
ils veulent nettoyer les îles aussi
parce qu'ici c'était la plage de ramos
ici c'était un grand succès dans les
années 70-80 la plage de ramos était
sensationnelle il ya énormément de
travail ici beaucoup de choses à faire
pour sauver la bête
aujourd'hui on peut plus du tout se
baigner aujourd'hui c'est impossible se
baigner c'est pas propre
y'a quoi là dedans c'est la baie de
guanabara il ya toutes sortes de
pollutions
[Musique]
le laisser-aller des pouvoirs publics et
une mauvaise gestion des déchets ont
ravagé cette partie du littoral
[Musique]
privé de plage les habitants des
quartiers nord n'ont plus le choix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour continuer de se baigner ils vont à
la piscine
[Musique]
l'eau de la piscine vient de la baie de
guanabara
elles rendent par là et là bas il passe
par un système de filtrage avec du
chlore dans cette machine est ensuite à
les rejeter dans le bassin alors la
veille
à ocala l'eau arrive par ces
canalisations et il ya une valve pour
éviter qu'il y ait trop de chlore dans
l'eau par l'ump- carnoët aux chorales
hypokhâgne au caire depuis qu'ils ont
créé la piscine de ramos je ne mets plus
les pieds à copacabana
déjà parce que j'habite de l'autre côté
de la ville et puis je préfère venir ici
parce que les gens que je rencontre ce
sont des gens que je connais depuis mon
enfance
donc des personnes que je vois depuis
que je suis tout petit et qui font
partie de mon milieu
j'aime bien tu sais le piscine à ossun
endroit très attachant c'est comme le
parfum français c'est super bon
[Musique]
kim à 11 heures du matin
la bière commence à couler à flots c'est
aussi le début de journée pour rosa da
elle sert ozanam a préféré c'est une
bosseuse 1 elle ramasse des canettes
quel âge as-tu 82 ans elle a 82 ans
cette femme 82 ans
et voilà elle part avec des énormes sacs
pour gagner quelques euros
et combien vous gagnez avec ses canettes
je gagne 70 centimes par kilo quand on
ne veulent pas mon sac 70 centimes le
kilo il faut avoir beaucoup de canettes
il faut beaucoup travailler
ça c'est mon peuple c'est les miens
ap
[Musique]
d'autres acteurs incontournables les
maîtres nageurs
voilà les pompiers de la piscine alors
comment ça se passe les gars aujourd'hui
les mois qui précèdent l'été sont plus
tranquilles les événements les plus
courants ce sont les noyades de
personnes qui ont trop vu des gens qui
deviennent difficiles à se courir
ils ne sont plus dans leur état normal à
quoi la chose la plus folle que j'ai vu
ici c'est une maman qui a perdu son bébé
d'un an et deux mois le bébé savait à
peine marcher il ne parlait pas non plus
ils l'ont laissé tout seul
et ils l'ont perdu on a mis deux heures
pour le retrouver
je trouve ça absurde un si petit bébé
c'est une énorme responsabilité et on
trouve beaucoup de cas comme ça ici il y
à beaucoup d'enfants perdus ici
allez salut au revoir ils ont une lourde
mission dans quelques heures ce sera le
grand roche regarde il ya de plus en
plus de monde qui est en train d'arriver
direction la baie de guanabara au nord
de rio plus d'une centaine d'îles et
quelques surprises comme l'île de pâques
étant ça va être une super balade vous
allez voir
fait j'en ai célèbre ici car c'est un
bon vivant mais aussi un agitateur
d'idées pour sa communauté
maintenant on va lui mais notre barbecue
sa dernière idée des excursions en
bateau dans les îles de la baie il n'y a
pas de raison que ces plaisirs ne soit
réservé qu'aux riches ça c'est la
piscine qu'on voit au loin
ouais c'est la piscine de ramos que tu
vois là
van pelt 1
la même promenade en bateau à partir des
quartiers sud de rio ça va coûter autour
de 40 euros
ici on le fait pour 20 euros et on est
lui-même les bières c'est beaucoup moins
cher
une formule low cost pour aller
découvrir les trésors de rio la plupart
des passagers de fées gens n'ont jamais
pris la mer il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont jamais été sur un bateau ils ne
sont même pas au courant qu'on propose à
tous ceux qui vivent dans les quartiers
périphériques ne sont jamais venus dans
la baie de guanabara
ils ne connaissent pas cette promenade
elle par exemple là bas elle n'a jamais
été filmé à tulle a déjà fait en bateau
non moi je ne suis jamais venu
elle non plus n'a jamais fait cette
promenade
le café
tous les week-ends barbecue et grosse
détente au programme
qatar
arrivé sur l'île de pâques et arago à l'
on va profiter de cet endroit il ya
beaucoup de touristes ici aujourd'hui
d'où notre voiture simone un gros bol
d'air loin de la favela
j'ai déjà ramené pas mal de gens ici des
amis aussi
cette promenade en bateau directement de
la piscine ao c'est toujours très
émouvant à pâques et à je me sens bien
vraiment très bien une ambiance petit
baigneur avec sa plage de sable fin et
ses pédalos kitsch allez-y faites un
tour comment on fait pour partir tourner
le volant juste un petit tour allait pas
trop loin
s'est il fait partie de la ville de rio
une de ses nombreuses perles accessible
à moins d'une heure de bateau j'adore
cet endroit
l'air est pur on peut faire du pédalo du
vélo en famille c'est rare un keita
c'est un petit paradis
tous les habitants de rio devrait
connaître cet endroit parce que pâques
est assez bon cela t'apporte paix herman
le décor vue du ciel s'est assombri la
baie de guanabara souffre d'une
pollution sans précédent
égouts directement déversées dans la mer
déchetterie à ciel ouvert sans compter
le boom de l'industrie pétrolière
[Musique]
le littoral de rio est en danger de mort
le gouvernement s'est engagé en vue des
prochains jeux olympiques à tout
nettoyer
une mission quasi impossible selon les
experts
[Musique]
seul le sud de la ville est encore
relativement préservée
[Musique]
le coin le plus surprenant de rio est à
quelques kilomètres de la ville
la baie de sepetiba pour s'y rendre par
la mer départ de la marina da gloria
yacht ou en barque hawaïenne il faut
dépasser les plages de son conrad hauts
et de bas
m
[Musique]
passé en face des îles cadas pour enfin
découvrir des plages sauvages et des
communautés de pêcheurs isolé
[Musique]
mais au moment
ap la télé
m
[Musique]
une région qui n'est plus à l'abri de la
pression économique que connaît le
brésil
[Musique]
à la tête d'une équipe de chercheurs
katia tente de mesurer l'impact de la
pollution en étudiant les dauphins de la
baisse
[Musique]
au sud de rio la baie de sepetiba est
l'une des plus grandes réserves au monde
de nos fins il y en aurait plus de 2000
[Musique]
katia à 25 ans elle est biologiste et a
dédié sa vie à la préservation des
espèces marines je les prends au poteau
pour faire un travail d'identification
j'enregistre les nageoires dorsales des
dauphins et grâce à ces images on peut
identifier les différents individus
ici dans la bête étudier leurs zones de
vie la densité de la population et leur
comportement
mon portable
[Musique]
katia a aujourd'hui en mission elle doit
se rendre sur une île assez étrange
[Musique]
une plage de 50 km de l'île de ganghwa
ratiba à l'extrême sud de rio
[Musique]
un spot confidentiel réservé aux
militaires ici et on joue au
débarquement
m
à touristes mais quelques communautés de
pêcheurs surnommé ici les cailles sarah
descendants d'esclaves métissées avec
des indiens
[Musique]
durant la semaine je dois et visité au
moins trois communautés de pêcheurs
cela peut être sur une île un jour une
autre île le lendemain ces communautés
vivent dans des coins isolés et sans
aucune assistance
je n'ai jamais été sur cette plage par
exemple et je n'ai jamais eu de contact
avec les pêcheurs de sept îles je vais
tenter de les rencontrer
katia enquête sur les causes de
mortalité des dauphins dans la baie elle
va interroger les cailles sahara
ils sont tous parents ici on est frères
cousins
c'est une grande famille de pêcheurs
c'est une communauté un peu fermé à
cause de l'accès restera en zone
militaire
mais on va tenter de discuter avec eux
leur expliquer que nous ne sommes pas là
pour les verbaliser ou leur causer du
tort notre attention c'est de collecter
des informations pour notre étude sur la
préservation des dauphins cela fait
combien de temps que tu caches ici ça
fait quinze ans durant toutes ces années
de pêche
il ya déjà eu des accidents avec deux
fois oui j'ai déjà retrouvé trois
dauphins dans mes filets
il s'agite ils cherchent à se libérer
on a dû découper le filet pour qu'il
s'échappe
les pêcheurs sont réticents aux enquêtes
de katia et les dauphins ne sont pas
leur principal souci
ici on ne vit que de la pêche mais le
problème c'est que cette plus en plus
dur les poissons sont en train de
disparaître
il ya beaucoup de pollution à cause du
trafic de navires
on peut plus pêcher autour des dauphins
y en a plein la baie il dévore tous les
poissons dans la baie il y en a partout
des dauphins partout et vous êtes en
faveur ou contre les dauphins
on n'est pas vraiment contre les
dauphins mais le problème c'est qu'ils
mangent beaucoup de poissons et c'est
les mêmes que nous on souhaite péché
alors c'est un souci c'est nous ou les
dauphins maintenant dauphin contre
pêcheurs l'avenir de ces deux
communautés est en sursis
l'équipe de katia continue ses
investigations
l'endroit où on va maintenant est
spécial ce sont des zones d'agrégation
là où sont concentrées un très grand
nombre de dauphins par centaines et
aujourd'hui comme il ya un peu de vent
on va trouver des regroupements
important étudier les dauphins pour
mesurer l'ampleur de la pollution
c'est le projet qu'a initié leonardo il
se charge aujourd'hui d'une mission
délicate
nous sommes en train de préparer des
ustensiles pour l'extraction des
échantillons de peau et de graisse de
dauphin
cette flèche va pénétrer la peau du
dauphin et sur l'embout on prélève un
échantillon comme ça on peut faire des
analyses génétiques et voir s'ils sont
contaminés appel plus facile à approcher
ce groupe-là a l'air facile
ils sont en train de jouer ensemble
il vaut mieux un groupe juste avec des
adultes
na li a des bébés dauphins avec eux
c'est risqué
ce que l'on voit ici c'est très rare
normalement cette espèce ne forment que
des petits groupes
et ici on a déjà pu compter 200 voire
300 ensemble dans la baie
ipad apple takeda la peau est là et ici
la grèce maintenant je vais l'emballé et
le mettre au frais pour le ramener en
laboratoire
sans témoin et quels sont les résultats
des analyses auxquelles je commençais
bio qu'on a déjà réussi à découvrir en
analysant leur génétique c'est que les
dauphins de cette baisse sont très
différents des dauphins de la baie de
paraty et au niveau de la contamination
on voit qu'il existe une contamination
considérable bien supérieur à la moyenne
on a découvert dans la graisse de
l'animal ils étaient contaminés par le
chlore et les pesticides
les analyses démontrent que la pollution
augmente sérieusement dans la baie
[Musique]
à cause est due à l'implantation de méga
projets industriels la construction
d'infrastructures portuaires pour
l'industrie minière et militaires a
profondément modifié l'environné
[Musique]
on
ce que l'on voit ici c'est le plus grand
complexe industriel d'amérique latine
qui a été construit et cela entraîne une
pollution importante
jusqu'à présent ils n'ont même pas reçu
l'autorisation leur licence d'opération
permanente car elles sont en train de
poser des impacts importants à
l'environnement ils ont été dénoncés par
la population avoisinante
il ya encore trois ou quatre ports qui
vont être implantées dans cette zone
on pense que la belle ne supportera pas
les impacts provoqués par l'installation
de ce type d'activité le risque avec
tous ces projets c'est que cette baisse
se transforme comme la baie de guanabara
au nord de rio
le brésil nourrit son appétit de
superpuissance les multinationales du
monde entier s'implante dans l'aber des
ponts de plusieurs kilomètres pour
approvisionner les navires ou non base
de sous marins nucléaires d'origine
française est en construction
[Musique]
ce port est encore en phase de
construction
maintenant ils veulent doubler la
surface avec deux immenses quai pour
recevoir des supertankers
des navires gigantesque pour le
transport de minerais cela va beaucoup
augmenter le trafic dans la benne les
pêcheurs ont déjà quasiment disparu du
littoral de rio alors quand le tour des
dauphins je ne sais pas comment ses
dauphins sont encore ici avec ton
d'impact dans la mer avec temps
d'interférences email pollution dégoût
trafic de navires pour un motif que
j'ignore
ils ont choisi de vivre ici
des colonies de dauphins font de la
résistance
et si l'on en croit les statistiques il
pourrait disparaître d'ici peu katia ne
protège pas que les dauphins
elle héberge aussi d'autres individus
dans sa chambre un invité de marque
un vent chaud venu d'argentine qui s'est
perdu sur les plages de rio
cette cavité n'est pas normal il est
trop maigre
vous pensez qu'il va survivre
j'espère bien les premières heures sont
les pires parce que l'organisme a besoin
de réagir alors ça dépend du niveau de
stress de la température s'est elle va
monter ou pas c'est le dixième que je
récupère ris je n'ai pu en sauver que
trois pour certains j'ai dû appeler le
samu mais ils sont décédés en trois
minutes
c'était trop tard il est trop maigre
totalement déshydratés katia lui injecte
un sérum c'est bon
wright arrête arrête enlève le
il n'a pas réussi à avaler toute la
quantité de ces roms il ne supporte que
la moitié donc on va pas insister il est
très faible
j'espère qu'il va s'en sortir
[Musique]
c'est le rendez vous le plus important
de l'année pour les lire je suis à
quelques minutes de l'ouverture de mon
défilé et je suis super tendu en sachant
que c'est le dixième des filets de ma
vie et que j'ai encore le trac
ce sont des mois de travail et tout d'un
coup tu dois tout présenté en direct
pendant quelques minutes
parfois c'est le mannequin qui est en
retard la lumière qui marchent plus m
c'est une tension difficile à contrôler
je ne suis pas encore habitué donc pas
[Musique]
ap
ultime célébration du
pour à la brésilienne un casting de rêve
et des bikinis qui feront bientôt le
tour du
merci merci
je suis soulagé je suis encore sous
adrénaline ah je sais pas ce qu'il se
passe la mousse de montchamp peine
n'arrête pas de déborder
ça doit marcher grâce à dieu
[Applaudissements]
finis les paillettes place au business
le lendemain dans le showroom de lenny
un mannequin cabine fait un défilé
personnalisé pour des acheteurs venus
tout droit des états unis c'est ce qui
va avec l'ensemble de ce que l'on vient
de voir
alors ici il ya de l'animation
bungie bonjour comment ça va très bien
et toi bonjour salut tu as bien contente
de voir votre nouvelle collection est
fantastique lenny a su conquérir les
étrangers en jouant le métissage des
couleurs et des formes plus adapté loin
du string des plages de rio
je suis très séduit par cet imprimé
ce type de vêtement on le vend très bien
aux états unis ça par exemple c'est plus
difficile parce qu'il est trop petit et
trop compliqué ce n'est pas le genre de
maillot qui marche là-bas le vrai bikini
brésilien ne se vend pas bien non plus
de ce genre tu peux adapter la taille la
vente des maillots brésilien et chaque
année de plus en plus importante
les américains sont tombés amoureux de
la passion et l'énergie qui vibre au
brésil
c'est très attractif on le voit dans la
mode
lenny soigne sa clientèle venue de loin
un quart de sa production se vend à
l'étranger
je vend autour de 300 mille pièces dans
plus de 200 magasins au brésil
[Musique]
jean 50000 aux états unis et la même
chose en europe
l'exportation est de plus en plus
importante les étrangers aiment le
bikini brésil des bikinis très chic qui
se vendent entre 80 et 200 euros pièce
sa nouvelle collection séduit il n' y va
savourer son succès à ipanema mais pas
sur la plage juste au dessus dans ses
buildings huppé du front de mer des
appartements grand standing avec piscine
sur le toit
un moment de détente entre copie
[Musique]
il va y avoir un mariage extraordinaire
demain ils ont reproduit une cathédrale
de 16 mètres de haut et plusieurs grands
chefs viennent cuisiner spécialement
pour les repas là où ce sera sur les
hauteurs de rio oui il y aura un
cocktail dès demain matin ça va être une
méga fête
loin des podiums et des paillettes au
pied du building
il y a les concurrents de l'aîné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le marché parallèle des bikinis que l'on
retrouve sur les plages de copacabana où
ipanema
exposés sur des parasols ambulants
impossible de les louper
ils font partie du paysage et dans cette
affaire il y à un homme clé daniel l'un
des plus gros dealer de bikini sur rio
entre deux boulevards à même la chaussée
les camelots viennent faire le plein
pour la journée
[Applaudissements]
je te fais le tout pour 400 euros c'est
bon
les affaires marchent
j'en vends 20 30 à un client 40 à un
autre chacun vient ici se fournir en
marchandises chaque matin et ça rapporte
beaucoup d'argent
ouais bah je fournis les vendeurs un peu
partout je fais toutes les plages de rio
de copacabana et ipanema arrive morizet
le meilleur vendeur de la plage salut
les copains
salut salut salut ça va les gars il ya
des nouveautés pour moi ouais
daniel tu vas bien salut ma belle
comment ça va j'ai choisir des pièces
hockey daniel tient montre lui les
nouveautés d'un coup de mon garçon
je crois que j'aime bien celui là
celui ci je vais le prendre aussi car il
est original des screenings aussi je lui
prendre entre 80 et 100 pièces
aujourd'hui c'est un jour spécial
ouais aujourd'hui c'est férié
il faut en profiter et quel est ton
record de ventes de bikini j'en ai déjà
vendu pour 2000 euros en une seule
journée
roméo agnel ont fait les comptes en fin
de journée allez bon travail
bon travail pauleta mais bungie atteint
pas les chats que du bon
ok
ça aussi c'est des bikinis son terrain
de chasse les kilomètres de plage tout
va bien le monsieur salut
c'est ça qui est ça c'est mon quotidien
ça y est moi je m'appelle moïse et la
guerre des bikinis va commencer depuis
combien de temps tu fais ce job ça fait
12 ans que je fais ce métier c'est assez
facile à l'isle d'abeau
on a la belle vie on travaille dans un
cadre de rêve et combien d'heures par
jour tu travailles sur la plage
je bosse pendant 7 à 8 heures sur la
plage paix qu'est né à l'eau bikini
bikini alors allo allo bikini alors on
fait juste un signal et combien de kilos
de bikini vous portez la grande kg en
moyenne
il faut être costaud bien sûr il faut
être bien en forme physiquement et
mentalement chez nous on n'y arrive pas
ce travail c'est pas pour tout le monde
il faut être en condition
ce n'est pas dans mon choix
vous me faites juste un petit signal
allô allô bikini le picking la
sauvegarde ce maillot regarde les
bikinis moody's s'engage alors ma jolie
comment ça va
sur le
rions tout se vend tout seul où ils sont
des milliers comme oasis a sillonné
front de mer et il y en a pour tous les
goûts par la saucisse sandwich naturel
il y a aussi une autre profession
incontournable ce sont les rabatteurs
saluts et saluts l'avenir une petite
chaise intrants à dégraisser nous comme
vous êtes mignonne
ils viennent vous alpaguer dès votre
arrivée
ils ont pour mission de vous louer des
transats et vous arrosez de cocktail
bien frappé
moi juste et sur le coup ces modèles
avec ce types d'imprimés c'est un succès
aussi ses strings
voilà ton maillot
un grand merci
comment tu t'appelles elle et moi c'est
moïse je suis là si vous avez besoin de
quoi que ce soit les filles comme ça
la journée a bien commencé mais je suis
un peu en retard j'aurais dû démarrer
plus tôt mais ça va marcher
si dieu le veut quelle est la différence
entre ces bikinis et ceux des magasins
je ne sais pas c'est les couleurs les
modèles sont confortables et surtout
c'est beaucoup moins cher
dans une boutique seulement 25 euros une
pièce sur la plage s'est dit aux gars on
arrive à copacabana
pendant ce temps là daniel le
fournisseur de bikini continue sa ronde
est-ce que tu as la gamme de maillots
style marin la complète me manque des
pièces je suis en rupture
il faut absolument du stock ouais j'ai
un peut de tout j'ai même de nouveaux
modèles que personne n'a encore pris je
viens de les lancer
je veux aussi du rouge j'en ai plus de
cela n'a pas dû xl il me manque du xl la
guerre je passerai ici plus tard je te
livrer des bikinis rouquin daniel merci
l'esa ont gonflé à cause du silicone de
plus en plus de femmes qui portent du xl
rails ce sont les tailles des plus
vendus on a dû s'adapter au marché
la loi
oui
il a installé sa petite entreprise dans
une favela des quartiers nord des
prénoms
ici les petites mains des bikinis low
cost s'activent
il ne participe à la fashion week mais
lui aussi a créé sa propre ligne
nous sommes ici dans mon usine de
confection
je suis en train de vérifier ce qui
vient de sortir parce que demain on va
mettre en vente les nouveautés mode base
et combien de bikini vous faites par
jour ici je ne calcule pas comme ça mais
c'est autour de 3000 elle c'est la
responsable du stock et combien le
bikini ici en stock
j'ai jamais compté mais il y en a
beaucoup je crois qu'il y en a peut-être
autour de 10 millions tu n'as pas tant
que ça et quelle est la valeur de cette
marchandise
ça doit tourner autour de 40 mille euros
gens vont sur toutes les plages
copacabana ipanema parra et maintenant
j'aimerais bien exportée en europe c'est
moi le plus gros fournisseur de bikini
de rio soyaux d'année daniel aimerait
conquérir le monde avec ses bikinis mais
pas vraiment besoin de se déplacer car
sur les plages de rio le monde entier
vient à lui les africains des hindous
des hommes d'affaires japonais
italien façon dolce vita ils sont des
millions de touristes à débarquer chaque
année il y a même
quelques égarés du tour de france axel
le français des favelas participe à un
tournage d'une publicité pour le
tourisme au brésil
le ballon va compenser va faire du vélo
on vient de sao paulo en vélo et on est
très content d'arriver à rio est pour ça
qu on est habillé avec les couleurs du
drapeau français
ça a démarré très tôt à 5 heures du
matin on va jusqu'à 5h pour l'après midi
mais
ça c'est rigolo comme comme plan comme
ambiance
on n'a pas l'habitude de jouer des
acteurs en plus maintenant c'est parti
pour la première séquence sur la plage
de copacabana
[Applaudissements]
riou fait son cinéma le brésil est
récemment devenue la sixième puissance
mondiale
le miracle est en marche le centre ville
est en ébullition
riou s'apprête à recevoir les deux plus
gros événement planétaire
la coupe du monde de football et les
jeux olympiques
et même le stade mythique du maracana se
refait une beauté
[Musique]
une fois son rôle terminée axel prend la
moto taxi pour rentrer chez lui
pour quelques euros c'est le meilleur
moyen de gravir ces ruelles escarpées
[Musique]
dans les favelas de rio il y a des
trésors cachés axel tient à nous montrer
un endroit peu commun à l'entrée de son
quartier des milliers de briques pour
une ville miniature sur plus de 300
mètres carrés
l'artiste oliveira a reconstitué les
bidonvilles de rio
un projet surnommé mourinho traduction
la petite colline voilà j'en ai au
projet associatif de la favela qui
s'appelle projet maurice qui a été
initiée il ya une quinzaine d'années par
des jeunes de la favela et le but c'est
de représenter le mode de vie de la
favela via une grande grande machel une
grande maquette pardon à base de briques
oliveira met en scène ici le quotidien
de ces quartiers en transformant la
favela en oeuvre d'art
[Musique]
voilà donc là tu as une représentation
de la vie dans les favelas de rio
donc ça demande qui est des pharmacies
qui a les hôtels dont et savez la la la
nasa veut dire l'internet café ils n'ont
pas oublié de mettre des petites motos
partout qu'il ne pratique pas le moyen
de locomotion dans la favela
bien sûr le beau père qui est la fameuse
unité de police d'élite qui intervient
dans les favelas quand ça chauffe
là on a la toute récente voix sur ip
paix unité de police de pacification qui
rappelle lé programme de pacification
qui sont en train de se dérouler à rio
là on a une cache de drogue on allait
les petits casto d'ecstasy ou de cocaïne
je suis passé quoi avec les trafiquants
qui sont bien armés qui protège comme il
faut le spot un jeu d'enfant devenu une
performance artistique
grâce à son travail oliveira a récolté
de nombreuses récompenses dans le monde
de l'art il peut désormais vivre de ses
talents je fais ça depuis 15 ans j'ai
commencé quand j'avais 14 ans pour
m'enfuir de la réalité que je vivais la
violence le trafic des drogues la police
je n'avais pas trouvé cette bonne idée
si j'avais pas trouvé ma voie
je serais tombé dans le mauvais chemin
ça a toujours été un jeu et ça fait bien
longtemps que j'ai pas joué les gamins
d'ici peuvent venir jouer mais ça dépend
pas n'importe lesquels il faut avoir au
moins 14 ans pour jouer et participer au
projet
oui
encore bonjour stopper votre voiture
sortait de la voiture il ya beaucoup de
braquages par ici on va fouiller le
coffre bon c'est bon vous pouvez y aller
[Musique]
entre le pain de sucre et le corcovado
la favela dax elle est voisine du
quartier de santa teresa
leur père de l'ancien bourgeoisie
portugaise une sorte de petit montmartre
carioca
[Musique]
tu vois patricia dans ce quartier il ya
beaucoup de très jolies maisons regarde
là il ya des millionnaires est juste à
côté des favelas ça c'est le brésil le
pays les extrêmes
bon ici on est là et ensuite on va voir
les ruelles du marché une architecture
féerique avec des châteaux sorti tout
droit d'un conte de fées
tu avais cette maison là où c'est beau
il s'appelle le petit château
il a été construit dans les années 30
par un homme très riche mais aujourd'hui
ce sont des appartements divisé à louis
tu peux vivre ici matin imagine t on à
tout comme une princesse du genre je te
veux ici
allez viens ici bien mon prince
à qui patrick ouart et ça c'est la
voiture de mes rêves les moulineaux oui
c'est ça
ses ruelles pavées et ses maisons de
l'époque coloniale sont aujourd'hui
devenues un lieu de rendez vous très
tendance le nouveau quartier des bobos
de rio entre marché aux puces et bar à
l'ancienne un nouveau pyjama pour toi ça
te plaît non j'aime bien ce genre de
vêtements j'aime beaucoup aussi une
étape incontournable
le bar de chettia groupe cela fait cent
ans que l'on y sert des spécialités
portugaises
c'est le bar le plus ancien de la ville
dans le pur style portugais il y allait
même claque tu retrouves à lisbonne le
symbole du quartier a disparu les bustes
pour remplacer le fameux tramway jaune
au grand dam de ses habitants saleh va
le dire alors comment ça va salut ça va
je te présente ma copine
patricia saluera vite rencontré salut
patricia l'a déjà vu cette image
oui c'est le tramway de santa teresa le
tramway est en larmes parce que
récemment il y a eu un accident mortel
et on a perdu un grand ami
le conducteur du wagon nelson allez
salut va le dire a très vite on a encore
plein de choses à faire
valeur 30
cet hommage à jean marc dupraz
morales
dans les hauteurs de santa teresa
axel fait un dernier crochet avant de
rentrer chez lui il a ses habitudes
un bus de fruits et légumes au prix
défiant toute concurrence savez comment
ça va
il est à combien de kilos aujourd'hui ça
combien de kehl aujourd'hui 70 centimes
le kg aujourd'hui c'est un bus à légumes
et fruits c'est une espèce de marché
ambulant qui vient près des favelas d'où
il vient une fois par semaine le jeudi
et là c'est un risque de fuite
le kilo c'est quoi 70 centimes le kilo
de tous parce qu'on peut donc tout
mélanger ensuite on soit ça va à la
balance et énonçant le prix 8 euros
ok merci à la prochaine
trente kilos de fruits et légumes pour
l'intendance de sa maison qui est en
plein chantier
le matériel nous avons pris trois mais
sauver de ses trois veuves et les
commandes ici vous voudrez m
[Musique]
axel et son ami raphaël ont décidé de
s'agrandir
[Musique]
ils veulent créer une chambre
supplémentaire avec une terrasse et un
nouvel escalier pour y accéder pour y
arriver ils sont épaulés par vince
hentsch le débrouillard de la favela
il faut faire vite axel veut être prêt
pour loger les touristes lors de la
coupe du monde de football qui aura lieu
au brésil l'année prochaine
[Musique]
je jure
pour la coupe du monde j'ai déjà regardé
sur internet les lits en dortoir ça va
coûter 150 euros la nuit étaient obligés
de rester une semaine dans l'hôtel ça le
pire c'est à dire tu vas rester une
semaine à rio ça va te coûter 1000 euros
une auberge de jeunesse avec les mecs
backpackers qui font qu'ils font le tour
du monde
alors imagine le moindre tale 2 3
étoiles sur les 380 euros la nuit on
sait pas on réfléchit c'est pas
d'actualité mais entre vous moi je pense
honnêtement une chambre tu l'as lu ici
soit très complète des ravages je
rajoute pas il s'écoule à pau mais ça
coûte 150 euros un lit en dortoir avec
15 personnes
moi je te ferai une chambre pour 250
avec la vision point de sucre est
tranquille tâter largement mieux
qu'ailleurs
tu te rends pas compte on est dans une
ville où il n'y a pas dit de tel tous
les prix vous familles qui pleurent par
10 par 15
ce qu'ils vont faire pour la coupe du
monde il vous mettre des bateaux de
croisière au port pour pouvoir louer
lowe's et les ont pas pris allez on y va
on y va on y va pas dans ce thriller
une erreur de calcul là non je crois que
oui mais bon je vais arranger ça c'est
pour pas se blesser
la providence est provisoire c'est juste
un petit accident
pas question de stopper les travaux ils
vont percer jusqu'au bout de la nuit
en fait
la grande prêtresse accueilli si les
fidèles
[Applaudissements]
le temple a été fondée par mon père
selon les directives du grand maître
d'orient qui est le patron de la maison
c'est le fruit d'un syncrétisme entre la
religion catholique et les populations
originaires d'afrique qui ne pouvaient
pas pratiquer leur culte
alors ils ont détourné les et comme
catholiques et mélanger leurs croyances
avec les populations indigènes
mais aujourd'hui c'est une cérémonie
gamme avec santa sarah la vierge des
tziganes
[Applaudissements]
c'est elle qui va bénir notre maison
bienvenue chez les gitans aux pays du
carnaval
rio est la capitale de tous les
métissages et de toutes les croyances
sous ses apparences folklorique avec ses
déguisements jeux danseuse de flamenco
ou pirate ship 6 ou danse ici pour faire
venir l'esprit de cigares
[Musique]
on a tous en nous un peu de sang tigane
on est tous un peu tzigane quelque part
on sort le jeu de tarot pour lire
l'avenir
[Musique]
vers le lendemain une autre partie de
cartes se joue dans le quartier de féjaz
mais cette fois pas de voyance à la clé
on ne se raconte pas d'histoires
l'heure est grave à regarde ce jeu là
c'est pas possible c'est quoi ces cartes
que tu me sors là qu'on arrivait à la
finale je ne peux pas le croire c'est
absurde ce que tu me fais si tu mènes
neuf ici il n'a pas la bonne carte c'est
pas possible
sérieux bien sûr c'est super sérieux
tiens pense elle l'a alors un sexy le
champion c'est l'un des nôtres
il est née et a été élevée avec nous
c'est une personne qui a toujours eu bon
coeur il n'a jamais trempé dans de
mauvaises affaires
c'est un grand ami il ya toujours aider
les gens ici
[Musique]
avec un ami entrepreneur ils distribuent
de la nourriture aux plus pauvres
c'est vraiment un bon gars un super ami
fait j'en veut nous montrer son
territoire et la révolution qui est en
cours pour comprendre il faut prendre de
la hauteur
la vue est superbe dix ans les quartiers
nord des favelas à perte de vue
[Applaudissements]
on peut voir la piscine de ramos là-bas
et la situation a changé ici
la situation a changé et avant que
c'était comment ici avant ici il y avait
beaucoup de constructions insalubres les
terrains vagues
c'était vraiment là il ya encore
beaucoup de bandits on entend souvent
des coups de feu
c'est très dangereux c'est le quartier
de marée nos volant d'or ici problème
c'est le trafic de drogue alors qu'il ya
beaucoup de travailleurs des bonnes
familles il ya un projet du gouvernement
il veut envoyer la police ce sera la
plus grande révolution de rio quand la
police va rentrer ici les habitants
pourront aller et venir se faire la fête
chez eux sans que personne ne vienne
leur dire de tout arrêter
rio ça va être la meilleure ville du
monde et ça va commencer avant les jeux
olympiques
ce sera une super vie lice dès cette
année ça sera bon
[Applaudissements]
peillon et ses amis ou croire en un
avenir meilleur à portée de main
[Musique]
ces quartiers autrefois mal famés
connaissent une véritable renaissance
retour à la maison les deux filles de
fait jean se déguisant paysanne pour la
fête du soir
mes filles se maquillent vous êtes prête
aujourd'hui c'est la saint-antoine une
fête de rue entre voisins chacun ramène
à plat à manger entre amis avec les
enfants donc on est là pour boire une
bière
les enfants des sodas on mange des
petits beignets et tout le monde s'amuse
parce qu'ici à ramos
maintenant que nous avons la paix avec
la présence de la police
on peut rester dans la rue et faire la
fête en famille sans danger et quoi
qu'on t'a pour les cmr chacun participe
avec des petits plats à partager comme
ces petits hot-dogs que nous avons
préparé des soucis allez on y va
nos vidéos
dans les quartiers nord la peur s'est
éloigné la ville s'est apaisée
la différence entre la zone sud et la
zone nord de rio
c'est ici en périphérie dans les
quartiers populaires et bien c'est plus
chaleureux ici tout le monde a des
problèmes
chacun fait comme il peut pour s'en
sortir mais au moins ici on s'entraide
tous ensemble
les gens et les siens espérait aussi
pouvoir profiter de la croissance du
brésil
un nouvel espoir pour que ces quartiers
continue de vivre en paix rio de janeiro
un rêve qu'on aimerait sans fin mais il
est temps de partir et quand vous
quittez rio il y à un mot soda
traduction la nostalgie d'une ville que
vous n'oublierez jamais on se souviendra
de moïse qui continuent d'arpenter les
plages mythiques au pied du corcovado
lenny la reine des bikinis cherche
toujours l'inspiration pour ses
prochaines collections
[Musique]
une épaisse
où cette seleçao n'a pas l'âme
axel le carioca d'adoption a presque
terminé ses travaux
le gringo de la favela est ici chez lui
au son de la samba qui enflamme les
ruelles de son quartier
pour la
voilà
dans les îles katia poursuit son combat
la jeune femme met toute son énergie au
service d'une seule cause
[Musique]
tout faire pour que rio gare de ses
lettres de noblesse spock rio continue
d'être surnommée la cité merveilleuse tu
fais ta atego quant à benoît weeds unis